[Music]
my name is James Nugent I'm a product
manager on the Android Enterprise team
thank you all for coming to both the
conference nose at this session as well
I promise that we were exciting before
we dive in I'd want to get a quick feel
for the people who are in the room so
who here is from a Android manufacturer
somebody makes Android devices
anyone from that maybe not okay anyone
from like a Android developer somebody
who develops Android applications pops
management applications okay fair fair
few anyone here from make a customer
somebody who deploys and enter Android
devices in their enterprise trying to
get a feel okay few more there who here
came to see Star Wars and is completely
in the wrong place okay okay I promise
you it's not as exciting but it's it
should hopefully have a few schools
along the way so I'm here to talk to you
about all the features that my team has
done in the Android pee release which is
just shifted to develop a preview a few
months ago specifically the features
relating to the enterprise and Mattin
and work so our team had three key
themes for the people ease the first one
was related to managed devices so these
are devices that are under supervision
and used in a work environment or
perhaps an education environment as well
these are things like the work profile
of people are familiar with that and
also fully managed devices when the
cooperation will only own the device and
we'll kind of oversee every operation
that's going on the device and a key
process within that area is device
provisioning how do we enroll devices
into management and supervision the
second key area that we focused on is
around dedicated devices now Android is
open source very extensible and we see
manufacturers like pushing Android ins
all sorts of weird and wacky places
these are devices that are used for a
single purpose so perhaps an airport
kiosk or a device that's used in the
warehouse for taking stock and taking
inventory so we made a lot of
investments in this to sort of mirror
the work that our partners were doing
and we'll talk about some of the some of
the enhancements and features we've done
there with a couple of demos and then
finally security security will be a race
that never ends you know work will
continue to invest here
what's nice about the work that my team
does is that the feature request that we
hear from enterprises around
enterprise-grade security just go into
the operating system and permeate out to
consumers shortly after that almost
immediately so we'll talk about some of
the enterprise features that are present
in the P release as well so let's talk
about - devices first as I mentioned
these are types of devices that are used
by what we call knowledge workers so
people who work in an office perhaps and
want to use their device either a device
that they bring themselves into the
office like a BYOD type scenario or a
device that they're given by their
employer so one of the big investments
that we made in p was really in response
to user feedback so back in android
lollipop i believe we introduced the
work profile this is where you have
effectively a separate user running on
the device and you have very clear
segregation between your work apps and
your personal apps this is a type of
work mode that works particularly
particularly well for BYOD so if we
imagine in my case at Google I own my
own personal phone but I want to get
access to my work email I can add a work
profile get access to all my corporate
applications but my employer has no
visibility and into any of the personal
activities I'm doing on the device so as
I mentioned this has been a feature of
Android since Android lollipop and some
of the feedback we got was around
improving the user experience there was
some challenges in this area so firstly
you'll notice on the screen on the Left
which is a screenshot from Oreo that all
of the work and personal applications
are mixed together you can see that
there's a small badge icon it's used to
denote like the personal calendar versus
the calendar so first the personal
application versus the work application
and we heard from we heard from users
it's hard to pass this duplicate list
you have this long list of applications
you have a personal email and work email
people didn't understand the difference
and this bright orange briefcase felt
slightly disconnected from the Android
system UI so we we made some changes to
that around that NP so firstly work and
personal applications are separated into
separate tabs within within the launcher
themselves so there's kind of an inbuilt
filter between work and personal modes
you'll notice that the the briefcase
icon is now change
to a nice shade of blue more in line
with the overall Android system UI which
using hits and hints of blue here and
there and you'll now notice that we have
a toggle right on the front you know
right up front and center on the on the
work tab giving users the ability to
turn off the work profile so you imagine
the use case here is that it's Friday
evening you no longer want to receive
any notifications with work chat or
email I can simply turn off the work
profile those apps are instantly
suspended I don't know longer received
notifications and in a Monday morning
when I'm back in the office and I want a
resume I simply turn that toggle back on
you can also see at the bottom there's a
there's a clear indication that this
this is the dream it of my organization
their management only extends as far
these applications and they have no sort
of visibility into what I'm doing on my
personal side so just to expand it
across this as well even we've added
some user education to make people aware
of this new paradigm so the first time
this is the first in the launcher is
open you'll see this nice this blue
tablet informs that this is the new home
for work applications and as mentioned
there before is to this toggle to turn
off work applications it's kind of up
front and center with some denote
demarcation is to say this is where your
organization's remiss kind of extends to
so I'm going to do a quick demo of this
I've won the wolfvision possible so this
is at a device running Android Oreo just
unlock it here quickly so you can see
here that I have got just a regular home
screen with a launcher and when I open
the home screen my launcher you can see
I have duplicate chrome icons I do
prefer contacts you look at calendar
here there and everywhere so you can
imagine that's quite difficult for your
users to pass and may you may have
accidental clicks if it is user to
select the wrong icon the actual ability
to turn off the work profile has been if
it has been available since its
inception it was actually buried up here
in quick settings it's already two
swipes down there and the further swipe
to the right to turn off work mode at
this point work notifications have have
been suspended and now when you open the
launch you see the sort of strange grey
icons everywhere which is not not ideal
at all so let's compare that to a device
running running P
quickly so again you know the familiar
Android home screen I can swipe up and
now that work and personal tabs all my
work my home applications are here I've
been I've got my personal photos my
personal email etc no duplication of
applications you can see that Android is
continuing to suggest applications to me
at the top and that will go across both
personal and work you can see there's
the badge icons appear at the top but
now within the work tab I have
everything can a group together neatly
there's no such mix-and-match of
applications and they're on a Friday
evening when I want to go home and have
a beer I just simply turn off the work
applications and everything stops and
then switching it back on
very simply back to the work tab on
Monday morning and I have to unlock
again sadly but sir oops and all my work
applications restore I can now start
getting email sadly so if we could go
back to the slides please
so the behavior I've just described
there is actually part of the default
system launcher that will launch with
Android P but if you're a developer of
your own launcher you too can sort of
join him in this experience as well
there is an API to request quiet mode
enabled that's what's turning on and
turning off the work profile and when
that when that when that action is
initiated there's a couple of broadcasts
that go out to the system and start to
say like work profiles available and
what purple is now not available and the
launchers can use that to kind of change
the colors of icons and marker mark apps
is disabled any application can query to
see if work mode is enabled by calling
that API there is it's quiet mode
enabled and there's further
documentation at that short link if
anyone's doing even more details so the
next piece of feedback we received from
users again related to the sock dual
persona of applications that you have as
a result of work profile quite a lot of
users have this muscle memory of using
the accounts which if you have multiple
accounts on a device say a personal
account and a work account most users
have sort of used to expanding the
sidebar menu and toggling between the
two account views with a work profile
because there's such such separation
between the two users previously there
was Nova
ability on from the personal side of the
work user and vice-versa too so in
Android P we've introduced this ability
to be able to switch between the same
instance oh sorry a different instance
of the same application that kind of
exists in both profiles so in this
example as you're seeing with the
animation here I've got the Google Tasks
app and you can see that I've got both
personal and work tasks I need to
perform so my personal side I've got a
dentist appointment etc and organizing
my wedding on my work side when I switch
over you can see that you know I need to
submit my superman' submit my expenses
and cancel my one-to-one meeting now
previously the user would have to like
return to the home screen find the other
application relaunch the application but
thankfully is mandroid P
any application can develop support for
this so there's some there's some
critical API is to support this the
first one is get target user profiles
that will return a list of the available
user profiles that are on the device
typically in a work profile that only be
one additional one additional user
profile we provide some icons that you
can use to just to facilitate the sort
of smooth UX you in the switching
process and you can also get like a
localized label to say that you know
this is what this is the account you're
switching to when the applications were
to launch you simply you simply call
start main activity and that will launch
the instance of the application inside
the other profile and again full
documentation at the shortlink but
what's crucial about this is it's not
just limited to google applications any
application that would potentially
reside both in the personal side and the
work side can implement these api's and
you too can terms to implement this
seamless switching between the two
instances QR provisioning so one of the
focuses for our team is to how to enroll
the device as quickly as possible so you
can imagine I'm an IT administrator I've
got a crate full of devices that I need
to provision and give out to my
employees as as soon as possible and we
support a number of mechanisms around
this there's NFC provisioning there is
zero touch provisioning which is which
is a launched last year and one of the
one of the methods we've spot for some
time is QR provisioning so this is where
administrators who can generate a unique
unique QR code containing that the the
details of the enterprise mobility
management solution that
enterprises using and that begins the
enrollment process what's new in P is
the ability to include Wi-Fi
configurations within that code so
historically if you wanted to add the
Wi-Fi con configurations you'd have to
like either enter this manually and
secondly what's most importantly about
this is actually the QR code reader
itself is bundled with the operating
system so historically if you wanted to
use QR code provisioning to enroll your
devices
you'd have to first connect to Wi-Fi
entering manual credentials to do so
download some QR code library to start
the process and then finally scan the
code now the good thing about this is
it's such an improvement of 30 seconds
per device because the QR code library
is included in the OS and you can
actually bootstrap connectivity straight
away so if you imagine 30 seconds per
and you've got a thousand devices that
quickly becomes quite a quite a large
time-saving what's nice about the QR but
the Wi-Fi configurations is that if that
Wi-Fi access point is within range
if the device just connects immediately
and then the enrollment process
continues setup wizard just continues to
go through we support a number of
different Wi-Fi credentials so things
like the name of the SSID the password
any any proxy details you want to
specify that's all can be encoded in the
QR code what you might notice is that
certificates are missing so this is an
early piece of feedback we've got from
partners since presenting this and
that's something to a look we're looking
to address in this up next Android
release and there's full documentation
on that short link there so when we
speak to IT administrators and customers
that deploy Android devices in the
organization we get constantly asked for
additional hooks and additional tools
that they want to configure on the
devices one of the gaps in Android for
some time has been around the access
point name the cellular AP end that you
need to add to a device sometimes so for
my life I'm a large cooperation I've got
a strategic deal with the carrier and
they may be given a custom APN
historically that would have to be a
manual process to add that into the
device but now we can do that over the
air through the EMM and we've actually
given more control to the settings the
editor to the IT administrator
particularly around the time and time
zone so
we've heard about all sorts of abuse
scenarios where if you imagine I'd say
I'm a truck driver and I've got an
Android device I may want to adjust the
time settings on my device so that I
appear to be on a break and then I would
know when we push jobs so suddenly we're
clamping down on that practice in
Android P there's a full list of APA a
full list of methods in terms of what we
support here and more on the linked
documentation so there's an ability to
add what we call an override APN that's
a custom APN and then enable it there's
ap is to set the time and set the time
zone and a whole sort of selection of
additional policies that we've included
like kind of lock down certain aspects
of the device that ranges from
disallowing airplane mode right the way
through to disallowing printings if your
organization has a problem with people
printing spurious amounts of paper we
now have the we now have the policy for
you one of the further further features
we built into Android P is the ability
to migrate DPC so for those who are not
familiar DPC or device policy controller
is what the enterprise management tool
will actually install on the device and
that's the actual application that's
enforcing all these different policies
sometimes it may be may be appropriate
for a customer to migrate to a different
DPC and there's a couple of a couple of
reasons why that might happen so it
could be that my management provider is
migrating from a from an old stack to a
new stack a new version of their of
their DPC is required so this could be
we now have the api's to support that
migration secondly the the EMM imagine
provider may be moving to the Android
management API this is something we
launched last year and provides a much
easier way for management providers to
offer the full suite of of management
services on their device so again that
could be another case for DPC migration
and then finally it could be the case
that a customer is actually switching
from one management provider to another
and they need to install the new DPC and
transfer everything over and maintain
all the policies there be no loss of
policy in this case okay so let's talk
about dedicated devices so as I
mentioned these are the devices that
often use for a single purpose or maybe
kind of a
ruggedized hardware that's been
augmented with barcode scanners and all
kinds of things we see lots of
innovation in this space within our team
so one of the kind of most popular modes
for devices like of this type is
something we call lock tasks so this is
locking the device to be only be able to
use either one on and full of
applications so you can see on the
left-hand side here there's an example
where a device is being locked to be a
point of sale in the current current
experience lock task mode only supports
a single application so you're only able
to lock to one application at a time
that's not that's certainly not ideal
and what we started to see was some of
our partners were implementing
workarounds around this because you know
locking to one application probably
isn't the the best solution and what
happened was those applicate those
there's workarounds tend to be quite
flaky we would like change something in
the OS and those workarounds would
suddenly stopped working so it was the
right time to invest in sort of a
platform wide solution and then secondly
the application developer themselves so
in this case this point-of-sale
application had to declare explicit
support for lock task mode they had to
include something in there in the
application that said I actually support
lock task mode now what happened here is
because this wasn't perhaps the most
people people people weren't aware of
this mode it's not a consumer feature
application developers simply didn't
include this and that severely limited
the catalog of applications that could
be used in lock task mode so anyway as
always good news comes in P so lock task
could now support multiple applications
and we have a custom launcher so we can
see here that I've selected six
applications and you know the user is
able able to use these things in and out
in come in and out of them as they wish
any application can be put into locked
ask mode so here I've got Chrome and
maps the Chrome apps developers have had
to do nothing to support this this lock
task mode and then finally we have more
flexibility around the launcher in terms
of what UI elements are showing and the
administrator has full control around
this so they can either choose to show
the home button they can choose that
certain settings have enabled or they
can lock everything down and there's no
eat there's no way for the user to to
use these things so I'm gonna give a
quick demo of this if you wouldn't mind
switching to the wolf reason
so one a good example of lock task mode
is devices that are locked as a kiosk so
this is something that could be say like
an airport so a library so within
Android P we now have support for this
and it's actually a very secure model as
well so when the user was actually
stopped using the device what I've
chosen to end their session that entire
user is actually deleted so all their
data goes with them so let me give you a
quick demo so you can hear there's some
sort like there's a splash there's a
splash screen here this can be fully
customized I've just given a very simple
example here for Google and then off we
go to start a session
I've got apologize this isn't the most
glamorous demo I've only got two
applications but you can imagine that
one of the applications could be like a
help application and you can see here
like this is just the applications here
so when the users actually finished
their session they can simply sit hit
end session and that will clear all of
that user data down or you can wait for
the screen to timeout in which case that
that process also happens and what you
can actually see here when it says
ending session is that process of like
deleting the user and actually creating
a new user in the background so that
when the device returns to the splash
screen a new users being created and
then use this next session can start
straightaway that's the first session we
go back to the slides please
a similar but slightly did a slightly a
slightly different example of this is
around shared devices so you can imagine
perhaps that I work work in a
supermarket and I will if the morning
shift and I pick up a device on a
morning and I use that to check
inventory I'm walking around checking
the shelves I login with my credentials
and it had I've access to my
applications at the end of my shift say
2:00 p.m. I put that device back on the
charging cradle and then the person
who's working the afternoon shift picks
up the same device logs in with their
credentials and they're often running as
well they quit the crucial difference is
here is this you know my application
data would remain entirely separate from
the second user they wouldn't be able to
read my email or even see any of the
kind of inventory scanning that I've
been up to and you know we provide a
very simple way for users to log in and
out in and out of this experience so let
me give you a quick example of this so
here you can see you can imagine I pick
up a device on a morning I log in I've
got a very secure password which I'm
about to show you here you can see I've
got my applications here so again very
similar to the earlier example but I've
got my selection of applications here
you can see actually I've got my email
address so like there's an email saying
hi Ian
so I could go about continue my duties
finish whatever I need to do and at the
end of my shift I would just select end
session sindermann comes along he logs
in with his credentials again we enforce
very strict password policies so if I
log in to cinder and email you can see
there is like an email for me and saying
like hello to syndrome
again there's no bit there's no
visibility of each of this data it's
effectively two separate users on the
device and again when sindermann is
completed you just simply log out so
there's obviously metric mechanisms to
add new users to the device so you can
imagine that the user may pick up the
device and scanner but scan a barcode to
log into the device we also support
signing in with a Google account and I
believe we also support logging in with
third-party authentication providers
well thank you one of the pieces of
feedback we hear from users of dedicated
devices so I mentioned like these
barcode type devices that we see seed in
use is around maintaining control of
their fleet doing critical business
critical periods it's a good example is
the holidays here so what the last thing
that they want to do what they want to
happen is for an OTA update to come and
effect all the devices cause a bunch of
regressions to their internal
applications then suddenly you know on
Christmas Eve you know all these
applications are kind of failing and
people can't make sales
so for dedicated devices we now
introduce this ability for them to
postpone like first sorry let me start
again for users of dedicated devices
we've now given customers the ability
for them to postpone updates for up to
90 days why 90 days why did I plug that
number of anywhere it's really suspected
for November December January that's
kind of that period they're wound up in
90 days now you know I'm sure you've
been to other talks at Google today
where we talked about the you know the
high investments were making in security
and how we want devices to make to be
updated all the time so you can imagine
introducing something like a 90 day
freeze period kind of goes slightly
against that you know we want devices to
be updated so to prevent devices being
locked out indefinitely and hopefully
receiving an update once this freeze
period is over we introduce a 90-day
cooling-off period there's a 90-day
buffer between any freeze period so in
that time any kind of OTA updates that
have been postponed or frozen out would
be pushed down to the device and applied
so this avoid this this avoids a
situation where an admin indefinitely
locks out a device that's a state we
don't particularly want to be in and
then all the new features all the new
security updates that come part with a
platform update we know will be applied
to in this cooling-off period and then
finally on security as I mentioned this
is this is an area where we will always
invest in there's a bunch of new
features in this area so let's start
with the separation of the work
challenge so you may have noticed
actually when Irene abled the work
profile on one of the first demos I was
prompted
to enter a password that's the password
that the administrator is required that
I have to enter to use the work profile
the administrator can actually put
specify some quality arguments around
that around that password they can
specify there has to be a certain length
it could actually be a very long
password now what happened in previous
for the versions of Android is if an
administrator has said right if you want
to use the work profile you now have to
use a 12-digit password that would then
manifest itself as the device password
as well so you'd have to every time you
want to look once it'll lock your phone
you're having to enter this 12 digit
password and then have the same again to
access your work profile so not
desirable most people want to use a
fingerprint or maybe a short password or
a short pattern so in P we've kind of
split these things up a little bit so
admins can require different pins and
passwords for the work profile versus
the purpose actual and locking of the
device so it's a bit of a usability win
but maintain the security integrity
around the work profile data leakage is
a is a consistent concern we hear from
customers who use android enterprise
devices particularly in highly regulated
devices or highly secured organizations
so we continue to plug gaps as they
because as they come up to our attention
so what we're actually introducing in P
is some additional controls about what
data can be shared in and out of the
work profile so many people be familiar
with the soft Android share icon the
share intent we're now giving
administrators the ability to turn that
off either one direction going out of
the work profile or into the work
profile or in no directions at all so
we've got full flexibility as to what
the direction in which data can travel
we're also preventing so you're also
given administrators the ability to
prevent extracting data via ADB so those
of you have used under a debug bridge
this is where you connect your connect
to your phone to your host PC and you
can use that to debug certain
information on the phone administrators
flag towards that this could be sort of
a potential security risk so we now have
a policy where extracting data from the
work profile by a DB can be disabled
verified device access continues to be a
key feature for around security this
when a device is perhaps communicating
with a remote server and has to strongly
attest to its identity so pistil you can
imagine where a device is kind of
signing into a mote server it's maybe
identifying itself using its IMEI or its
serial number to retrieve whatever
configuration it needs to the difficulty
is that IMEI and serial number can be
quite easily spoofed and it could be the
case that the device has been
compromised and it's kind of
misrepresenting itself the remote server
so devices like the pixel now support
Hardware backed off indication so we now
have api's in the platform as well so as
well as presenting my hardware
identifiers I can also present a key or
a secure hash of those identifiers that
a strong indication that I am the device
who I'm claiming to be so we now have
api's in the framework that allow you to
use either google's keys or your own
keys and certificates to authenticate to
remote services and then finally not the
most sexy feature I do apologize but
when investigating incidents or security
breaches administrators like the ability
to interrogate log files or on the
device to understand what's been going
on we now have unique identifiers for
both network and security logs so the
reason for that is that if the logs have
been somehow somehow have been tampered
with or logs have been removed or
entries have been removed sorry
there will be easy easy to detect
because there will be some sort of
discrepancy and the unique IDs and then
we finally we've expanded the coverage
of security related actions so there's a
sort of additional kind of level of
security actions that will now be added
into the log files there's even more
listing and on security at that short
URL and I'd encourage you all to to read
this in you at your leisure so in
summary there are lots of great features
coming Android P I've talked about the
sort of the three key areas that our
teams work on so things are the managed
devices the work profile fully managed
devices dedicated devices where we see a
lot of innovation from partners that you
wouldn't expect
then finally security everything I've
described here is public information
feel free to take photos or kind of get
started with it it's all part of the
Android P release and there's full
documentation and developer guides that
Villopoto android.com
[Music]